but we begin here with breaking news
overnight at least eight people are dead
and several others injured after an
apparent trampling at a concert in
houston
the fire chief says the crush of people
happened when the crowd lunged toward
the stage in the middle of the rapper
travis scott's performance
crowd began to to compress towards the
front of of the stage
okay and that caused some panic
and it started causing some injuries
people began to fall out
become unconscious
and it created additional additional
panic
about 17 people were taken to the
hospital in ambulances many suffering
from cardiac arrest it is believed about
50 000 people were in attendance at the
sold out astral world music festival at
nrg park when the concert opened guests
on friday morning we're going to show
you what the scene was hundreds of music
fans overran the gates making their way
to concert grounds a travis scott who
was friday night's headliner is also the
concerts organizer
the performances scheduled for today
have been cancelled we will continue to
watch this as details unfold but again
at least eight dead at a concert in
houston just awful